ви знаєте товариство це так маразматично
коли ми людину ділимо на дві частини
політичні погляди і все решта хороша
людина якщо людина
балатувалася поділяю погляди
репрезентує партію відверто про
Московського
антидержавницької якої були і є опзж як
би там їх забороняли чи не забороняли ця
Партія не має бути представлена в
Україні у жодному з керівних органів
влади і жодним представницьким мандатом
і чесно кажучи це так само маразматично
Що вже майже рік іде повномасштабне
вторгнення партія заборонена А всі Хто
були обрані від опзж собі красиво сидять
осінній залі Верховної Ради а очільниця
монобільшості Розказує що у них
конструктивна співпраця Я перепрошую в
опзж бувших і теперішніх навіть якщо
вони заборонені конструктивно співпраця
з державою-агресором і ці люди прямо чи
опосередковано працювали на вбивство
наших військових на захоплення
українських територій їм дуже весело
тому що таке враження що хтось
вигороджує їх у цій сесійній залі і
законопроекти а їх я нагадаю чотири не
виносяться на порядок денний сесії
889 щодо наслідків для депутатів після
заборони їхньої партії
83-48 відкликання з керівних посад
представників упсж Уявіть собі комітет
свободи слова очолює представник опзж
тому зі свободою слова в Україні повна
халепа
76-94 достроково припинення повноважень
таких депутатів
73,62 призупинення повноважень
представницьких органів і місцевих
депутатів не мають бути люди які все
життя працювали на Московську федерацію
зараз при будь-якому мандаті Але ж ні